[Music]
but in point of fact spirit has already
accomplished this in principle the
consciousness that is aware of its
disruption and openly declares it
derives existence and the universal
confusion and derives its own self as
well it is at the same time the fading
but still audible sound of all this
confusion this vanity of all reality in
every definite notion vanity which knows
itself to be such is the double
reflection of the real world into itself
once in this particular self of
consciousness qua particular and again
in the pure universality of
consciousness or in thought in the first
case spirit that has come to itself as
directed its gaze to the world of
actuality and still has there its
purpose and immediate content but in the
other case its gaze is in part turned
only inward and negatively against it
and in part has turned away from that
world towards heaven and its object is
the beyond of this world
paragraph 525 is the penultimate
paragraph of this section and we saw
that a resolution was taking place in
the two previous paragraphs now we're
getting to see that you might say
condensing into a determinate form which
is by the end of this paragraph and then
even more determinately in the next
paragraph and then in the paragraphs to
come leading us to a beyond so Hegel
begins this paragraph by referencing
what had just happened in the previous
one saying in point of fact Spirit has
already accomplished this in principle
it has brought it to fulfillment and in
principle here is translating on Z so
intrinsically in itself is probably you
know better than than just in principle
provided that that we we understand that
what we mean here is that something has
been outlined something has been
initiated but it's not yet actually done
so what is what is being done Hegel
talks about this this transition to a
higher consciousness from the spirit of
culture the the way to address the you
know discordant and you might say super
abundant realm of culture where nothing
quite seemed to match up to anything
else things turned into their opposites
and you know we had this this sort of
sophisticated consciousness which could
talk glibly about all these different
things then we had a more sullen as
Miller translated taciturn honest
consciousness which doesn't really know
what to do other than to try to simplify
things or go back in time instead Hegel
says no we have to go through this and
by doing so we're gonna reach a higher
consciousness and we might ask ourselves
well what historical period does Hegel
have in mind here or is this a dynamic
that can repeat multiple times I think
it really we should we should view it as
the latter so he says the consciousness
and he's talking here about this
sophisticated consciousness that
identifies but also is that a distance
from its culture and even is discordant
with itself he says the consciousness
that is aware of its disruption and
openly declares it divides existence and
the universal confusion what is this
universal confusion the real world and
we might say well what do you mean the
real world you know that of objects no
the real world of culture of meanings
which don't turn out to be stable which
don't turn out to be arranged in neat
hierarchies where everybody knows their
place which turn out to be subversive
and subvert able right so he says it it
divides this Universal confusion and
divides its own self as well so what we
see here again is a repetition of the
very dynamic that we saw earlier on
several times most particularly in the
section on skepticism repeated again
here in this one we should look at the
phenomenology
as not simply a nice progression where
we we're done with one stage and we
finish with that and thank God it's
behind us and now we move on to the next
we have these sort of cycles where
things are getting bigger and more
concrete and that's what's happening
here
so Hegel says it's at the same time the
fading still audible sound of all this
confusion so nice oral metaphor Hegel
actually does talk in this this passage
about a kind of laughter that doesn't
make it into the translation how is the
individual consciousness supposed to
make sense out of where it is and then
move to something hired it appears as if
there's no basis for it to work with
anymore there's nothing it can really
rely upon just a heap as or to use the
word that came up earlier a medley of
different notes so what does this then
bring in Hegel here is going to talk
about vanity I title kite you know and
we think about what
means manouse --fill to distinguish two
senses vanity here in English that are
often easily mixed up you know for
example in in the book of Ecclesiastes
where it says vanity of vanities all is
vanity x' which is a sentiment
corresponding to this it doesn't mean
that every everyone is vain in the sense
of making too much of themselves as a
matter of fact where we translate as as
vanity in the original Greek was K
no-doc SIA and and K knows means empty
you know the canosa that theologians
talk about the emptying that that the
Christ figure too took on or you know
underwent or however you want to talk
about it it's coming from the same word
so vanity means emptiness and when we
talk about a person being vain that's
really a secondary derivative sort of
meaning which stems from the fact that
they are priding themselves on things
that really are empty like if you think
that because you've got a great car or
because you've got a million thumbs up
on you know this or that Facebook post
or YouTube video that you know you're
really hot stuff well that I mean it
could be that you are but in that case
it won't be that thing showing it you
probably have a book or something that
you can back it up with I don't know
what you're do in case of the car thing
but in a lot of cases it really is empty
and people pride themselves on that here
it's more the original sense of the
emptiness of these things as being
revealed what do we mean by emptiness
not just you know avoid we mean the fact
that they don't stand up under scrutiny
which is what the dialectic has been to
have stable meanings things that we can
rely upon so he goes on and he talks
about the vanity of all reality and
every definite notion every concept
vanity which knows itself to be such now
that's an interesting thing in this case
does the name
negative of a negative turn into a
positive is there an advance in knowing
not only that everything else is vain
but even your own attitude towards it is
also vain is that an advance is that a
success or is that sometimes just a mode
of cynicism it depends on where we're
going with this
people do remain moored in this Hegel
talks about you know there's double
reflection of the real world into itself
it's really an internalization on the
part of self-consciousness which has
been taking its cues from the social
world hasn't it's been looking to see
where it fits in with wealth and state
power and try and understand you know
itself as a noble self consciousness and
and you know how language fits in it
really is connected with the world and
if the world is totally screwed up that
means self consciousness is going to be
screwed up as well so what is the way
forward Hegel tells us that there's a
sort of bifurcation happening here this
awareness of the vanity of everything
can happen in the particular self of
consciousness qua particular as an
individual person or he says and here's
where we're gonna move into the next
section in the pure universality of
consciousness or in thought now that may
sound rather abstract but keep in mind
that for Hegel thought covers quite a
range so you know it's not as if you you
have feelings and those aren't thought
as well or you know pictures and images
and those aren't thought all of that
thought just as much as for you know
somebody like take heart for example you
know the kind of thinking that we're
doing when we're reasoning that's
thought right the work of the intellect
alone unaided by imagination but
imagination is also thought and so is
sensations of pain and pleasure those
are thought as well willing is thought
willing against his thought we can go on
and on and on with us
so Hegel goes on and he says in the
first case spirit that's come to itself
directed its gaze to the world of
actuality and still there has its
purpose and immediate content so you
know maybe it holds down a job or it
occupies a certain social role and even
though it feels like this is all BS none
of this really matters it continues on
with it and it can find moments of
meaning within it and it doesn't have to
be an unhappy State but that's not where
the advance occurs Hegel says in the
other case its gaze is in part turned
only inward and negatively against it
and in part is turned away from that
world towards now I've got on the board
you know going downward because I
started drawing my schema before you
know deciding exactly what I was gonna
do but we could talk about heaven or we
could talk about the depths right it is
turned away from that and the object for
that in terms of no longer just the
particular self but the universality of
thought is this beyond this yang Zeitz
this this thing that is outside of the
world outside of self consciousness now
where is that that's what the entire
next section is going to be directing us
towards
in that aspect of the return into the
self the vanity of all things is its own
vanity is itself vain it is the self
centered self that knows not only how to
pass judgment on and Shatter about
everything but how to give witty
expression to the contradiction that is
present in the solid elements of the
actual world as also the fixed
determinations posited by judgment and
this contradiction is their truth
looked at from the point of view of form
it knows everything to be self alienated
being for self is separated from being
in itself what is meant and purpose are
separated from truth and from both again
the being for another the extensible
meaning from the real meaning from the
true thing and intention thus it knows
how to get correct expression to each
moment in relation to its opposite in
general how to express accurately the
perversion of everything it knows better
than each one each is no matter what its
specific nature is since it knows the
substantial from the side of the
disunion and conflict which are united
within the substantial itself but not
from the side of this union it
understands very well how to pass
judgment on it but has lost the ability
to comprehend it this vanity at the same
time needs the vanity of all things in
order to get from them the consciousness
of self and therefore it creates this
vanity itself and as the soul that
supports it power and wealth are the
supreme ends of its exertions it knows
that through renunciation and sacrifice
it forms itself into the universal
attains to the possession of it and in
this possession is universally
recognized and accepted state power and
wealth are the real and acknowledged
powers however this recognition and
acceptance is itself vain and just by
taking possession of power and wealth it
knows them to be without a self of their
own knows rather that that it is the
power over them while they are vain
things the fact that in possessing them
it is a it is itself apart from and
beyond that
exhibited in it's witty talk which is
therefore its supreme interest and the
truth of the whole relationship in such
talk this particular self quoi this pure
self determined neither by reality nor
by thought develops into a spiritual
self that is of truly universal worth it
is the self disruptive nature of all
relationships and the conscious
disruption of them but only as
self-consciousness in revolt isn't aware
of its own disrupted state and in the
snowing it has immediately risen above
it in that vanity all content is turned
into something negative which can no
longer be grasped as having a positive
significance the positive object is
merely the pure eye itself and that is
RuPt in consciousness in itself this
purest self identity of self
consciousness that has returned to
itself
we end this section with paragraph 526
which I should point out ends with a
movement to this this higher level
he says the positive object by this time
is merely the pure eye itself something
we've encountered many times which are
now going to take a new determinate form
and the disrupted consciousness in
itself this is pure identity of self
consciousness that has returned to
itself so the disrupted consciousness is
you might say in a certain sense being
slough off or at least it seems so at
this time and how do we get to that
point
well Hegel here is going to a little bit
earlier in this this paragraph which is
quite a long paragraph he's going to
talk about the contradiction the vitas
Brook being the truth the VAR height
that self-consciousness has has realized
so rather than arriving at a truth which
is sort of a coherent cohesive
everything you know making sense fitting
in together is rather a realization that
these parts don't align with each other
and because of that because of its own
consciousness being tied in or that it
doesn't have a sort of place that can it
can withdraw itself to and be a unified
consciousness at least not a
consciousness of the individual within
the world because that very contradict
the contradiction you might say in fact
said so let's look at what he says he
says in that that aspect of the return
to itself what is that aspect of the
return to itself this this move to the
object that is the beyond the yang Zeitz
of this world and of its own
consciousness
it says the vanity of all things is its
own vanity it is itself vain and we
talked just a moment ago about you know
ìtell kite and and what it means and
it's its primary sense so we've got the
vanity of things as individual things as
not just
well objects but also understood in
terms of say powers or moral
qualifications such as good and bad of
the world as a totality and also of the
self
all of these are revealed as as vain so
he says if the self centered self that
knows now self centered self is a little
bit of a tricky translation here I think
that it does make sense that Miller
chose that through the exams elped
alright is is what he's talking about
there's helps of course itself through
Zeke zonda being for itself the kind of
self that has this reflexivity that is
attentive to its own position that's
paying you know some some sort of
attention not just to the world but how
it's seeing the world and whether it's
right about that or wrong about that
right that's part of what it means to be
to be for itself so in this case I think
Miller's translation is not that close
but it is felicitous insofar as we're in
this stage we're not just sort of losing
ourself in this this contradictory world
of culture we're holding our self back
as you might say a consumer or you know
another way of putting it is Hegel talks
about it here it is as a judge as a in
the old sense of Judge critic right so
it does actually make sense so let's
come back now to the passage so this
this Saul Center itself knows not only
how to pass judgment but earth hilum on
and shatter but retsyn about everything
these are the modes in which it is
engaging the world shattering you know
saying things about it there's this idle
or witty chatter and then making
judgments actually deciding what things
are a little bit deeper he says it also
knows how to give witty expression to
the contradiction that
present in the solid elements of the
actual world is also in the fixed
determinations posited by judgments so
even in the act of engaging in judgments
it's realizing that those judgments
themselves are not entirely what they
would pretend to be this is not the
skepticism that says oh I should
withhold judgment
I should engage and what the Greeks the
skeptics called Epoque a you know sort
of holding away from those things or you
know is the the Stoics and then later of
course Descartes and well so many people
in between them talked about you know
suspend the judgment a little while
don't don't give a cent to it right away
that's not what's happening here
judgment is being engaged in but the
knowledge is that those fixed
determinations of the judgment
themselves are not as solid are not as
reliable as one would like them to be so
it seems that everything is in a way up
for grabs he goes on and here's where he
says they're contradiction is their
truth the the truth that's been arrived
at the insight the wisdom is that things
are contradictory not just to each other
but also to themselves the good isn't
totally good the bad isn't totally bad
and we could go on and on with examples
as we've done for a paragraph after
paragraph so I don't need to rehearse
this now he says look at from the point
of view of form this is where it gets
very interesting what do we have going
on here he says it knows everything to
be self alienated not just alienated
from everything else self alienated
within anything that we we look at that
has you might say the least trace of
subjectivity being in itself and being
for itself are not harmoniously can
coinciding in addition to this being for
another we notice we don't just have
being for it's often in its
also being for another is not exactly
coinciding say with its being in itself
or its being for itself we have a
contradiction that's more complicated
than just two things contradicting each
other so he goes on and he says here we
go from the point of view of form it
knows everything to be self alienated
being for itself is separated from being
in itself what is meant and purpose from
truth and from both again the being for
another the extensible meaning from the
real meaning from the true thing and
intention notice that he's talking here
about what is meant right what is
intended he's talking about the language
that we're using or the if we want to go
a little bit broader the communication
because we can we can communicate not
just with words but with our actions and
with our effects and with our attitudes
towards each other none of these things
are actually matching up to each other
so we have a incoherent let's say a
local eco here at the globally
incoherent world full of contradictory
things that nonetheless we still have to
wend our way through and make sense out
of at least to get through each day so
what else can we say he says this this
this self-centered you know self knows
how to give correct expression to each
moment in relation to its opposite so
it's sophisticated it understands how to
get by in this world how to make sense
of this world how to judge things he
says it knows better than each what each
is no matter what its specific nature is
since it knows the substantial from the
side of disunion and conflict which are
united within the substantial itself but
not from the side of this Union it
understands very well how to pass
judgment on it now notice this key point
here that Hegel is saying it understands
how to pass judgment on it
but it has lost the ability to
comprehend it
it doesn't fully understand or loan it
back up a little bit we must distinguish
here between we might say two senses of
understanding one of which encompasses
the thing and does so in a way that
actually overcomes those contradictions
that harmonizes them this is the realm
of the concept for Hegel the big riff
and then there's understanding in the
sense that we more typically use it
understanding how understanding that and
it this is get a lot but it's not able
to carry out that synthesis that process
of conceptualizing it in the full sense
they can picture it it can imagine it it
can make judgments on it it can take it
apart it can show where the
contradictions lie but it cannot
actually overcome or reconcile the
contradictions it was a very important
point this distinction by the way
between different levels you we might
say of understanding this is not one
that Hegel is coming up with on the spot
although it does have its own peculiar
spin because of Hegel's stress on the
baqia the concept the notion this has
been running throughout philosophy from
really the time of Plato and Aristotle
all the way through the medievals
and well into the modern age where Hegel
thought it get lost sight of he
criticizes in other works the philosophy
of the understanding which doesn't grasp
that there is a difference between
understanding and some higher faculty
now let's go on so it says this vanity
at the same time needs the vanity of all
things in order to get from them the
consciousness of self the person here
has become you might say almost addicted
to a world that doesn't fully make sense
or can't I find who they are outside of
that if the world suddenly did make
sense they would lose their
reason for being whatever it happens to
be so he says let's look at two things
that we began with power and wealth
these were taken as being actual
spiritual powers as things we could rely
upon says power and wealth are the
supreme ends of its exertions it knows
through renunciation and sacrifice it
forms itself into the universal attains
the possession of it this in this
possession is universally recognized and
accepted where did we see this this is
the noble consciousness and in doing its
work for the state power then he says
this recognition and acceptance is vain
this is a very important point the
recognition that it's been seeking this
entire time which is at the very core of
self-consciousness to have on air cannon
to understand what you are where you fit
the meaning of your life can only be
granted in part through the mediation of
the other and what you're getting from
the other turns out to be vain in this
case that's a big problem so he goes on
and he says state power and wealth are
the real and acknowledged powers but
this recognition and acceptance is vain
by taking possession of power by taking
possession of wealth it knows them to be
without itself of their own knows that
it is the power over them the individual
is the power over them they are vain
things so he says in it sweetie talk
it's able to demonstrate this it
pizzette it's a part and beyond them
right
this is exhibited in it's witty talk
which therefore becomes its supreme
interest why does that become its
supreme interest because that's more
important because that actually is
closer to the reality of things than
these shadows over here that seem to be
dominating Society so he says in such
talk this particular self qua this pure
self determined neither by reality nor
by thoughts isn't that an interesting
way to put it determine either by
reality nor
I thought what the hell does that mean
well determined made to be what it is
neither by thought the universal nor by
the realities that its encountering what
is determining it then this is where we
have although Hegel's not using the word
here the realm of human freedom right
self determining that's something that
human beings do so he says it develops
into a spiritual self that is of truly
universal worth this is where the new
transition is coming in so he says it is
the self disruptive nature of all
relationships on the conscious
disruption of them but only as self
consciousness in revolt is it aware of
its disrupted state as so long as it
remains to go a little bit back further
trying to hold on to maybe I could be
the noble consciousness maybe this maybe
I could invest myself here or here and
the world would make sense maybe maybe
maybe if you know any of these risks are
still you know engaged in and there
isn't a kind of knowing despair at this
point
wow this this really is all I've got
here and none of it adds up to what it
was supposed to be in the first place if
you don't pass through that you can't
move on Hegel saying to this point to
the spiritual self that has truly
universal significance and what is this
going to be framed as for Hegel the
positive object becomes the pure eye
itself the disrupted consciousness you
might say is just a way to get us there
right and this is the return to itself
now this has only been accomplished as
we started out by saying here in
principle we have an entire section
ahead of us to map out where we're going
but what what is Hegel talking about
here he mentioned in the previous
paragraph of heaven beyond here he's
talking about the pure eye and talking
about thought what he's really going to
be discussing in the next section though
is faith or belief
how is the acting to fit in here well
this closes this section and we'll find
out that as we move into the new
material